[Music]
brexit britain has already completed one
journey around the Sun everything has
changed and yet nothing has either and
nowhere is better than Birmingham to
show it Birmingham's
an interesting one it's a city which
you're going to the odds against many
people's expectations narrowly voted to
leave during the referendum it's split
almost exactly down the middle much like
the rest of the country a lot of people
thought that that narrowly vote might
lead to a change of politics in this
city during the general election we'll
just take a look at this in fact far
from leading to a slew of Conservative
MPs being elected as they thought they
might including in this constituency in
Birmingham Selly Oak look at this
instead labour increase its vote share
by 15 percent the Tories only by much
more paltry 3 percent and a lot of that
labor vote came with and from the you
keep vote which was hugely down there
for politics in this city
is more or less as it was before the
referendum but with all this negotiation
still to come the question is as
Birmingham cellphone brexit sweet or
sour
I've got beef of grexit yeah you got
while you got beef with brexit who's
there you've probably got beef with most
things with ace what why have you got
beef with brexit and I just think we
were better better together really so
you're worried about it um I was worried
I'm slightly worried about what is gonna
happen really but I think we should just
probably to wait and understand really
what's gonna be next step before the
election when everyone thought to resume
would win a landslide majority remain as
felt their calls was irrevocably lost
many accepted the results and wanted to
get on with it but the election muddied
the water and consequently a year later
the way forward seems even less clear
than it was the people's will is now
opaque and though remain errs might have
a spring in their step levers aren't
budging either we're really confident we
want people in Britain to be confident
obviously where else that's drinkable
they're feeling very confident of us
well exactly it would be confident with
you yeah and you are as well oh I think
you know we've got to have faith in our
own ability as a country and our ability
of driving businesses and we've done it
for centuries
so you don't have to travel that far
outside Birmingham before you true-blue
Tory Warwickshire footplate the reason
made very comfortable with sup place you
know to replace the probably remind them
where she grew up
we just M splitting here for second with
before the election the naughtiest thing
Teresa may had ever done was run through
a field of wheat like this but now
calling it at all
surely beat it because before the
election we have one democratic mandate
one people's will governing the
politicians and how we breaks it now we
have two and 365 days on it's made the
most complicated negotiation in British
history since the war yet harder still
Louis could all Sky News